Guten Tag. Aktaq ist mein Name und ich bin hier als Assistent-Erstin.
Zuerst möchte ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen. Dann kommen wir gleich zu Ihren Beschwerden. Ist das in Ordnung?
Ja.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Yasmin Retterspitz. Ein schwieriger Name.
Können Sie bitte Ihre Nachname langsam stabilieren?
Ja. Retterspitz schreibt sich R-E-T-T-E-R-S-P-I-T-Z. Retterspitz.
Das ist der Name einer Pflanze.
Eine Pflanze auf Deutsch.
Welche Art an Pflanze?
Es ist eher so Richtung eines Gewürzes.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Frau Retterspitz.
Ich bin eine Frau. Yasmin.
Ich bin 40 Jahre alt.
Und wann genau sind Sie gebogen?
Am 11. Januar 1985.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich wiege 68 kg.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,74 m.
Welche Hauser?
Das ist Dr. Meier.
Okay, Frau Retterspitz.
Welche Hauptwählschwerte haben Sie im Moment? Was führt Sie zu uns?
Ich habe seit 24 Stunden sehr starken Schmerzen im Bauch.
Aber die Schmerzen haben mehr rechts und unten im Bauch.
Sind diese Beschwerden plötzlich oder langsam begonnen?
Die haben relativ schnell angefangen.
Aber sich dann gesteigert.
Innerhalb weniger Minuten bis eine Stunde waren sie ziemlich stark.
Sie sagen, dass Sie mit der Erseidschilie mitgegeben haben?
Ja, seit einigen Stunden tut jetzt der ganze Bauch weh.
Am Anfang waren die Schmerzen nur rechts unten.
Im Bereich des Unterbauches und der Leiste.
Können Sie bitte diese Schmerzen genauer beschreiben?
Im Anfang waren die Schmerzen eher stechend.
Seit einigen Stunden sind sie eher dumpf geworden.
Sie kommen und gehen, aber sie sind immer da.
Aber sie sind manchmal sehr stark.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10?
Im Anfang vielleicht bei 5 bis 6.
Aber wenn so eine Schmerzwelle kommt, dann ist es eher 7.
7? Ja, ok.
Haben Sie dagegen etwas eingenommen?
Nein, bis jetzt nicht.
Möchten Sie sofort eine Schmerzmittel?
Nein, ich kann das noch aushalten.
Es wird jetzt nicht so lange dauern.
Aber ich halte es jetzt noch aus.
Haben Sie die Schmerzen bekannte Auslöser für die Schmerzen?
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Ich war gestern seit langer Zeit wieder im Fitnessstudio.
Mit einer Freundin zusammen.
Da haben wir am Ende Handeln gehoben.
Die Handeln waren ziemlich schwer.
Nach diesem Handel-Hochheben-Hochstemm habe ich diesen Schmerz gespürt.
Sie sagen, dass Strahlen in der Leiste ausbekommen.
Da begann der Schmerz.
Da war er am Anfang.
Im Unterbauch, rechts und in der Leiste.
Da war das zuerst.
Und in den letzten Stunden hat sich der Schmerz auf den ganzen Bauch ausgebreitet.
Am Anfang, wo genau haben Sie die Schmerzen?
Jetzt, am Anfang, im Bauch.
Rechts und in der Leiste war der Schmerz am Anfang.
Gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen, stark oder linder?
Nein.
Ich versuche mich, ruhig zu verhalten.
Ich lege mich auf die Sofa und auf den Rücken und die Knie etwas angestellt.
Das ist noch am besten.
Bewegen ist gar nicht gut.
Habt ihr in den Schmerzen bisher?
Nein, so etwas habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Warst du deswegen beim anderen Arzt?
Nein, es ist erst seit 24 Stunden.
Es ist erst seit einem Tag akut.
Gibt es weitere Beschwerde?
Mir ist jetzt ein bisschen übel.
Seit einigen Stunden ist mir übel.
Ich kann gar nichts mehr essen.
Ich kann nur noch etwas trinken, aber ich habe bisher nicht erbrochen.
Ich habe manchmal das Gefühl,
dass es im rechten Unterbauch etwas dicker ist.
Es fühlt sich etwas geschwollen an.
Wo genau?
Im Bereich der Rechtenleiste.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Nein, kein Fieber.
Wie ist der Appetit in letzter Zeit?
Normalerweise ist mein Appetit gut.
Ich vertrage alles bis auf Gluten.
Das vertrage ich natürlich nicht.
Ich habe eine Glutenunverträglichkeit.
Aber seitdem ich da eine Diäteinhalte fühle,
fühle ich mich damit sehr wohl.
Aber mein Appetit war immer gut.
Aber seitdem jetzt die Spauchschmerzen da sind,
habe ich keinen guten Appetit.
Das ist aber jetzt erst in den letzten Stunden.
Wie usattest du die Glutenunverträglichkeiten?
Ich habe oft Durchfall, Bauchschmerzen und auch Durchbälle.
Aber dann wurde das diagnostiziert.
Das war jetzt vor 20, 15, 20 Jahren.
Ich halte jetzt eine glutenfreie Diätein-Kost ein.
Damit geht es mir recht gut.
Haben Sie eine solcher Zeit?
Nein, ich habe mein Gewicht gehalten.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang oder Wasserlassen?
Wasserlassen ist in Ordnung.
Stuhlgang habe ich normalerweise zweimal pro Tag.
Aber seitdem ich jetzt die Schmerzen habe,
habe ich bisher keinen Stuhlgang gehabt.
Seit wann? Keinen Stuhlgang.
Ja, seit 24 Stunden.
Seitdem ich die Schmerzen habe,
habe ich jetzt seit 24 Stunden.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Normalerweise?
Nicht immer gut.
Mein Beruf ist sehr anstrengend als Lehrerin.
Da habe ich manchmal Stress.
Dann schlafe ich manchmal nicht so gut.
Aber es gibt dann wieder Nächte, wo ich gut schlafe.
Das ist wechselhaft.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Ein- oder Durchzuschlafen?
Mehr Durchschlafen.
Durchschlafen ist schlechter.
Haben Sie Müdigkeit?
Nein.
Haben Sie Gusten oder Atemnot?
Nein, habe ich auch nicht.
Haben Sie Sonnenbrinnen oder Föllegefühl?
Nein.
Ich habe kein Problem mit.
Haben Sie Herzzahnen, Herzstolpern oder Brustenge?
Ist bei mir nicht bekannt.
Haben Sie Schwindelig oder Schwarzforderung?
Nein, habe ich keine Probleme mit.
Ist Ihre Periode regelmäßig?
Ja, sie ist regelmäßig.
Ich gehe auch regelmäßig zur Benäquologin,
zur Vorsorgeuntersuchung.
Das war immer stabil.
Wollen wir Ihre letzte Periode?
Vor zwei Wochen.
Ist es möglich, dass Sie schwanger sind?
Das glaube ich nicht.
Leiden Sie an einem bestimmten krönen Erkrankungen,
wie Bluthochdruck, Ruckerkrankheit?
Ja, ich habe ja einmal, was ich gesagt habe,
diese Glutenunverträglichkeit.
Dann habe ich vor 20 Jahren,
also vor 20 Jahren,
einen Morbus Hodgkin.
Das wurde aber gut therapiert.
Ich bin da im Augenblick beschwerdefrei
und alle Kontrollen waren dann auch gut.
Ich bin da bei meiner Hausärztin,
immer regelmäßig auch in Kontrolle.
Aber das ist alles unauffällig.
Damit bin ich sehr zufrieden.
Ich habe noch eine vergrößerte Schilddrüse.
Auf der rechten Seite ist ein Knoten.
Aber da war ich auch bei Schilddrüsen-Spezialisten.
Er sagt, es ist ein Knoten,
aber dieser Knoten ist nicht aktiv.
Man kann ihn erst mal beobachten.
Man muss nicht operieren.
Ich nehme da auch ein Medikament ein
und bin damit aber zufrieden.
Die Schilddrüse ist etwas vergrößert,
aber nicht sehr stark.
Behindert mich nicht.
Können Sie bitte wiederholen,
seit wann diese Morbus Hodgkin therapiert?
Im Alter von 20 Jahren ist das entdeckt worden.
Als ich 20 war.
20 Jahre her.
Da wurde das entdeckt.
Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Ja, ich bin als Kind am Blinddarm operiert worden.
Da war ich 10 Jahre alt.
Dann wurde ich noch einmal operiert am linken Unterarm.
An dem Knochen, an der Speiche.
Da hatte ich mir den Unterarm gebrochen.
Da hatte ich einen Sportunfall.
Das wurde operiert.
Dann hatte ich zweimal einen Kaiserschnitt geboren.
Das war vor 12 Jahren und vor 10 Jahren.
Vor 12 Jahren und vor 10 Jahren.
Haben Sie zwei Kinder?
Ja, zwei Kinder.
Sind sie gesund?
Ja, sie sind gesund.
Haben Sie Probleme mit dieser Operation?
Nein, alles ist in Ordnung.
Haben Sie Regen- oder Gelegenheit?
Ich nehme für die Schildrüse ein.
Das Mittel heißt L-Teroxin.
Kennen Sie Dosierung?
Ich nehme für die Schildrüse 75.
Ich nehme eine Tablette morgens.
Und weitere Medikamente?
Nein, keine Medikamente.
Gelegenheit haben Sie?
Zum Beispiel?
Schlafstörung?
Nein, da nehme ich keine Tabletten.
Haben Sie Allergien gegen das?
Nein, ich habe alles vertragen, bis auf Gluten.
Sonst habe ich keine Unverträglichkeiten.
Okay.
Frau Rettelspitz, rauchen Sie?
Nein, ich habe noch nie geraucht.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke hin und wieder ein Glas Wein.
Vielleicht pro Woche, insgesamt drei Glas Wein pro Woche.
Ein Glas Wein täglich?
Nein, drei Glas pro Woche.
Insgesamt in sieben Tagen trinke ich drei Glas Wein.
Rhythmisch?
Nein, ich trinke es in den letzten Tagen.
Rhythmisch, muss ich fragen?
Haben Sie Kontakt mit irgendwelchen Drogen gehabt?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Sie sagen, dass Sie sind Lehrerin?
Nein, ich bin verheiratet.
Ich bin verheiratet mit zwei Kindern,
wohne mit meinem Mann zusammen und den Kindern.
Ich habe gesagt, dass Sie sind Lehrerin.
Ja, ich bin Lehrerin für Deutsch und für Englisch.
Mit wen wohnen Sie?
Mit der Familie.
Sind Ihre Eltern,
gibt es eine bekannte wichtige Erkrankungen?
Zum Beispiel Suckerkrankheit, Bluthochdruck oder Krebs usw.
In der Familie?
Leiden in Ihre Eltern.
Mein Vater ist jetzt 68 Jahre alt.
Vor zwei Jahren wurde bei ihm Darmkrebs diagnostiziert.
Er wurde daraufhin operiert.
Er bekam anschließend noch eine Chemotherapie.
Bisher waren die Kontrollen alle gut.
Aber man sagt, man muss das noch länger beobachten.
Aber die letzten zwei Jahre nach der Operation
ist das gut verlaufen.
Er hat aber noch eine starke Suppenflechte.
Mein Vater.
Ihre Mutter?
Meine Mutter ist 67 Jahre alt.
Sie leidet unter einem entzündlichen Gelenkräumer.
Ist das gut angestellt?
Das war alles.
Ich habe noch eine Schwester.
Die Schwester ist 38 Jahre alt.
Sie leidet unter Endometriose.
Haben Sie Bruder?
Nein, ich habe keine Bruder.
Nur eine Schwester?
Ja.
Wann warst du das letzte Mal im Urlaub?
Im Urlaub war ich das letzte Mal in den Weihnachtsferien.
Da war ich eine Woche lang schielaufen in Österreich.
Wie ist Ihr Impfstatus?
Alle Kinderkrankheiten,
Kinderkrankheiten,
Covid-19.
Die Impfstatus lasse ich immer kontrollieren.
Sie hat im Herbst darauf geschaut.
Sie sagt, das ist ausreichend.
Ich brauchte keine Impfungen.
Das wird immer kontrolliert.
Treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Ich mache Jogger.
Ich habe immer einen Impfstatus.
Ich habe jetzt wieder angefangen.
Das war gestern.
Das erste Mal wieder seit langer Zeit.
Aber sonst jogge ich zweimal in der Woche.
Wir sind jetzt fertig.
Haben Sie noch Informationen, die wichtig sein könnten?
Haben Sie Fragen?
Ja.
Ich kann mir überhaupt nicht erklären,
woran ich haben kann.
Diese Schmerzen werden jetzt auch noch schlimmer.
Das macht mir schon Sorgen.
Ich höre, dass Sie Sorgen machen.
Wir werden alle notwendigen Untersuchungen
Schritt für Schritt durchführen.
Sobald ich die Ergebnisse habe,
erkläre ich die Situation.
Ich kann noch etwas essen und trinken.
Sie können nicht essen oder trinken.
Ich soll nicht dann bleiben.
Ich mache.
Dann haben Sie 10 Minuten Zeit,
sich vorzubereiten.
Ich habe noch etwas zu tun.
Das ist jetzt so.
Sie können sich vorzubereiten.
Sie können Sie in den Sprachen begriffen.
Danach haben Sie eine Frage.
draussen?
Wie ernähren Sie sich?
Arme, Ballaststoffreiche oder Fettarmee, Ballaststoffarme?
Ich esse nicht besonders fettreich.
Da achte ich immer ein bisschen drauf, dass mein Gewicht nicht weiter ansteigt
und ich versuche, mich ausgewogen zu ernähren.
Aber ich muss eben darauf achten wegen der Glutenunverträglichkeit,
dass ich da keine Nahrungsmittel zu mir nehme, die glutenwältig sind.
Aber ich komme damit ganz gut zurecht.
Und meine zweite Frage ist, haben Sie bemerkt,
dicker Leichtbereich?
Ich habe schon gesagt, ich habe den Eindruck, es ist etwas geschwollen
in dem Bereich. Es ist etwas geschwollen, also dicker.
Danke.
Wir haben gesagt, dass Sie, lässt der 24 Stunden, keine Stuhlgang haben.
Gehen Sie wind ab?
Ja, etwas, etwas, aber nicht so viel.
Aber wie gesagt, normalerweise habe ich zweimal pro Tag Stuhlgang.
Und jetzt, seitdem ich da im Studio war gestern,
vor einem Tag seit 24 Stunden, habe ich jetzt keinen Stuhlgang gehabt.
Rechte im Leistungsbereich, haben Sie bemerkt, dass Sie eine geschwollen?
Es ist etwas dicker. Die Leiste fühlt sich etwas dicker an.
Hab ich nicht bemerkt, aber ich habe das nicht genau untersucht.
Vielleicht müsste man noch eine Frage stellen.
Hatten Sie in letzter Zeit oder in den letzten Tagen vielleicht einen Unfall?
Unfall, ja.
Sehen Sie gestürzt oder so etwas?
Die andere Frage wäre vielleicht noch, ich weiß nicht, ob die Eltern strahlen die Schmerzen eventuell in den Beinen aus.
Also die Schmerzen strahlen nicht ins Bein aus.
Ein Unfall habe ich nicht gehabt.
Ja, einen Unfall habe ich nicht gehabt und die Schmerzen strahlen nicht ins Bein aus.
Keine Strahlung, aber die Patiente fühlt sich die Schmerzen ganzer Bauch.
Ja, inzwischen im ganzen Bauch, seit einigen Stunden,
in den ersten Stunden war der Schmerz nur rechts unten in der Leiste und des Unterbauches.
Da hat es im Anfang weh getan und ist dann in den ganzen Bauch gegangen.
Ja, am Anfang stichend jetzt dumpf.
Ja, mehr dumpf jetzt und weh dem fällig.
Ja, so ist das.
Aber vielleicht, der Kollege sollte noch etwas Zeit haben, sich vorzubereiten.
Wir haben keine Zeit.
Wie bitte?
Könnte wir fangen, ich fange ein Juni.
Ja, ich kann gerne anfangen.
Guten Tag Herr Oberarfs.
Ich würde Ihnen gerne eine Patientin vorstellen, die ich gerade in der Ambulanz gesehen habe.
Frau Jaswina Wetterspitz, ein Meter, 40 Jahre alt,
Meter 74 cm groß und 68 kg schwer.
Die Patientin stellt sich bei uns aufgrund seit einem Tag bestehender, relativ plötzlich aufgetretener,
stehender, dumpfer, wellenförmiger, starker Schmerzen im abdominalen Schmerzen.
Waren die Schmerzen im gesamten Bauraum, im gesamten Abdomen?
Am Anfang im Guinall-Region aufgetreten und dann seit 1 bis 2 Stunden am ganzen abdominalen Schmerzen.
Am Anfang haben die Schmerzen rechts im Guinall-Region, rechter Unterbauch.
Im Laufe der letzten Stunden haben sich die Schmerzen im gesamten Abdomen ausgebreitet.
Im Anfang war der Schmerz auch gleich dumpf, oder war der Schmerz eine andere Qualität?
Am Anfang war der Schmerz stechend, und im Laufe der Zeit ist er jetzt mehr dumpf geworden.
Sie haben gesagt, wellenförmig.
Die Schmerzintern in 10 Städte wurde mit am Anfang 5 bis 6 und dann 7 von 10 auf der Schmerzskala bewertet.
Die Patientin sagte, die Schmerzen strahlen in den rechten Inguinall-Regionen aus.
Da haben Sie in der Inguinall-Region begonnen und sind dann in das gesamte Abdomen gewandert.
Sonst strahlen die Schmerzen ins Bein aus oder nicht ins Bein?
Strahlen die Schmerzen nach Peripher aus ins Bein?
Entschuldigung, ich habe nicht gehört.
Strahlen die Schmerzen nach Peripher, also ins Bein, ins rechte Bein aus oder nicht?
Nicht aus Stammer in der Bein.
Gut. Wann war der letzte Stuhlgang bei der Patientin?
Normalerweise die Patientin hat 2-mal am Tag Stuhlgang.
Und jetzt habe ich 23 Stunden keine Stuhlgang gewesen.
Also seit dem Schmerzerreignis, seit dem Auftreten des Schmerzes kein Stuhlgang.
Kein Stuhlgang.
Ja, okay. Gibt es Erbrechen?
Nein, Sie haben Übelkeit, aber keine Ämzen.
Kennen Sie den Fachbegriff für Übelkeit, Medizin?
Nausea.
Okay, ja. Es besteht Nausea, aber keine Ämzen.
Gut. Hat die Patientin eine Erklärung für ihren Schmerz?
Gibt es eine Ursache?
Wir haben die Patientin gestern zusammen mit ihrer Freunde,
Fitnessstudie gehen und nach den Haltern auch gehoben,
eine Schmerz im rechten Leiste aufgetreten.
Okay. Geht es Sie regelmäßig in dieses Studio, die Frau, die Patientin?
Nein, die Patientin regelmäßig jogge 2-mal am Woche und Fitness-Salon kein regelmäßig.
Also sie war gestern zum ersten Mal wieder im Fitnessstudio und hat Handheldraining gemacht?
Handheldraining wohl?
Und dabei hat sie dann den Schmerz verspürt.
Das ist richtig.
Gut. Gibt es sonst Auffälligkeiten? Hat die Patientin ein Unfallereignis gehabt oder so etwas?
Die Patientin sagte, dass wir gegen Stress und Beruflichtstress nicht gut...
Ich habe gefragt, gibt es ein Unfallereignis in der Anamnese?
Ist die Patientin gestürzt in den letzten Tagen?
Nein, nein.
Aber nach Sport und Fall, Linken unter den Knochen?
Ja, aber das war ja vor einigen Jahren.
Ich frage, gibt es akut einen Unfall in den letzten 3 Tagen?
Nein, nein.
Leidet die Patientin unter chronischen Erkrankungen?
Ja. Sie haben Morbus Hodgkin vor 20 Jahren gut therapiert und jetzt waren gut.
Vor 20 Jahren eine Lymphogranolomatose oder Morbus Hodgkin und diese Krankheit gilt als auspahndelt, als austerapiert.
Sie ist beschwerdefrei.
Und nodulär Schilddrüsenerkrankungen?
Sie hat eine Schilddrüsenvergrößerung.
Kennen Sie den Begriff für Schilddrüsenvergrößerung?
Kann jemand von den Kollegen helfen?
Stromer.
Stromer, sehr gut.
Ist das eine Stromer-Diffuser, eine Allgemeinevergrößer oder hat sie noch einen Befund in einer Schilddrüse?
Sie haben in einer Schilddrüse eine Knoten, aber die ist eine gute...
Gutartig.
Man kann sagen, sie hat eine Stromer-Nodosa.
Das ist der Begriff Stromer-Nodosa, selbst wenn es nur ein Knoten ist.
Die Stromer-Nodosa ist wahrscheinlich ein unverdächtiger Knoten, also kein kalter Knoten oder kein ganz heißer Knoten.
Und wahrscheinlich hat sie eine euthyriote Stromer-Nodosa, euthyriote.
Euthyriote heißt normale Stoffwechselage.
Nicht hypotheriot, auch nicht hypothyriot.
Euthyriote Stromer-Nodosa wird die behandelt, medikamentös?
Ja, sie nehmen ein Schiff, L-Teroxin und namens Ultrox 25 Mikrogramm, ein Tablet 95.
75, L-Teroxin, L-Teroxin 75 Mikrogramm, einmal pro Tag.
Gibt es sonst die Gekronische Erkrankungen bei der Patientin?
Hab sie nicht.
Denken Sie noch an Gluten.
Ja, Gluten.
Das ist wichtig.
Wenn die Patientin die Diät nicht einhält, dann hat sie wieder geschwerden.
Das ist nicht gut.
Ich würde diese Informationen im Allergien sagen.
Ja, man kann es sagen.
Aber ich würde ruhig sagen, die Patientin leidet seit 15 oder 20 Jahren.
Besteht eine Glutenunverträglichkeit?
Ja.
Glutensensitive, interuptiv, heißt das wahrscheinlich dann mal meisten.
Aber die Patientin ist weitgehend beschwerdefrei unter Diät.
Sie hält eine Diät ein, sehr konsequent wohl und damit hat sie jetzt kaum oder keine Beschwerden.
Sehr gut.
Seit 20 Milligramm.
Ja, ist die Patientin schon einmal operiert worden?
Sie haben das eben mal erwähnt.
Ja, sie haben als Kind, sieben Jahren,
eine Appendectomie durchgeführt worden.
Man kann sagen, im Kindesalter, mit 10 Jahren, erfolgte eine Appendectomie.
Noch für Operationen?
Ja, und vor acht und zwölf Jahren,
eine Säzerian durchgeführt worden,
für ihre Kindesgeburt.
Ein Kaiserschnitt ist eine Säkziosex,
Säkziosex.
In Deutschland zunehmend häufig gemacht.
Die Statistik steigt der Säkziosex,
vor zehn bzw. zwölf Jahren.
Das war noch eine Operation.
Sie haben das vorhin mal erwähnt mit dem Unterarm.
Unterarm Fragto nach Sportunfall?
Ja, können Sie sagen, welcher Knochen?
Die Patientin hat gesagt, die Speiche,
der Speichenknochen war gebrochen,
der Unterarm hat zwei Knochen,
Elle und Speiche.
Kennen Sie den Begriff der Speiche auf medizinisch?
Der medizinische Begriff Speiche.
Und relativ oft vor als Bruch?
Das ist der Radiusknochen.
Kennen Sie den anderen Knochen?
Wie heißt die Elle?
Ulna.
Radius bricht häufig,
gerade bei älteren Menschen,
wenn sie sich am Handgelenk abstützen,
die Patientin war mit 18 Jahren operiert.
Weil der Radius wahrscheinlich im Bereich des Schafftes
oder wo kompliziert gebrochen war,
da musste man das ostiosecentetisch versorgen.
Wir haben also zwei Bauchoperationen
bei der Patientin in der Anamnese.
Drei Bauchoperationen,
zweimal Sektio und einmal eine Appendentinie.
Können Sie etwas zur Familienanamnese sagen?
Leiden die Mutter an Rheumatid Arthritis an.
Wie alt ist die Mutter?
67 Jahre alt.
Leidet ein Rheumatoid Arthritis.
Und gibt es eine andere Abendentinie?
Ja, die Abendentinie.
Gut, können Sie etwas zur Familienanamnese sagen?
Leiden die Mutter an Rheumatid Arthritis an.
Und gibt es noch den Vater?
Den Vater, 86 Jahre alt.
68, 68.
Und Kolonkarcinom Leide.
Und operiert wurden.
Und dann Chemoterapie.
Wann war das die Diagnose des Kolonkarcinom?
Ich vergesst.
Vor zwei Jahren.
Vor zwei Jahren, Diagnose Kolonkarcinom
mit OP und Chemoterapie.
Hat der Vater sonst noch eine chronische Erkrankung?
Ja, er habe Schubbeinflichte
und Fachbegriffe.
Zoriasis.
Sehr gut.
Wenn Sie überlegen, fällt Ihnen eines sehr gut.
Der Vater leidet an einer ausgebrechten Zoriasis.
Zoriasis ist die Schumpenflechte.
Und gibt es Geschwister?
Ja, sie haben eine Schwester.
38 Jahre alt.
Und eine endometriose Leide.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtdiagnose?
Aufgrund der Symptomatik.
Verdacht auf eine Inguinalherne.
So wie Ileus.
Also Inguinalherne.
Mit folgendem Irgendwie.
Mit der Diagnose.
Mit folgendem Ileus.
Es macht ja nun nicht jede Inguinalherne einen Ileus.
Viele Menschen haben eine Inguinalherne.
Man kann wahrscheinlich davon sprechen, es handelt sich um eine
inkarzerierte Inguinalherne.
Ein eingeklemmter Leistenbruch.
Wenn der Bruch inhaltlich ist.
Und die Leistenbrüche.
Das ist ein sehr guter Leistenbruch.
Wenn der Bruchinhalt sich sozusagen.
Und Daminhalt in die Bruchforte reindrückt.
Das erklärt vielleicht im Anfang den stechenden Schmerz.
Der sich dann im Laufe der Stunden.
Im gesamten Abdomen ausbreitet.
Weil es zu einem Ileus geführt hat.
Oder zu einer Ileus-Symptomatik führt.
Das erklärt vielleicht weshalb die Patientin jetzt keinen
Stuhlgang mehr hat.
Man muss sich stärker werden und das gesamte Abdomen erfassen.
Es handelt sich um ein akutes Abdomen bei der Patientin.
Wenn die Colon oder andere dann perforationen.
Eine akute Abnummer.
Denken wir.
Das kann auch dann passieren.
Man muss also die Patientin akut schnell diagnostizieren.
Und gegebenenfalls auch dann notoperieren.
Dass die Patientin die Abdomen.
Die Patientin die Abdomen.
Das kann man auch nicht operieren.
Dass diese in-carze Werte leisten.
Herr Anje, möglichst bald operiert wird.
Das passiert ja in dem Bereich durchaus nach Anstrengung.
Deshalb nach dem Handeltraining.
Hat sie sich wahrscheinlich nicht gut beraten lassen.
Aber es ist auch eine weiche Leiste oder so etwas.
Und dann ist es passiert.
Differenzial diagnostisch kommt vielleicht noch.
In dem Bereich gibt es etwas tief versetzt.
Ein Schleimbeutel, eine akute Bursitis.
Die kann ähnliche Schmerzen machen.
Aber die macht keinen Ilios.
Das ist auch schmerzhaft.
Aber das ist eine andere Charakteristik des Schmerzes.
Die Patientin ist schwer krank.
Sie muss akut angeschaut werden.
Und diagnostiziert werden.
Deswegen die Frage der Patientin.
Darf ich etwas trinken oder essen?
Bitte sagen sie bleiben sie nüchtern.
Sie bekommen einen Zugang, eine Infusion.
Ein Tropf, dass sie Flüssigkeit bekommen.
Aber Essen und trinken darf die Patientin möglichst nicht mehr.
Können wir denken,
relaps von Morbus Hojkin
oder wegen Leistung Knotung?
Also bisher war die Patientin ja was den Hodgin angeht.
Die ganzen Jahre über sehr unauffällig.
Und wenn jetzt ein so ein akuter Schmerz auftritt,
nach einer körperlichen Begründung.
Dann ist es ein sehr unerwarteter Schmerz.
Das ist ein sehr unerwarteter Schmerz.
Wenn es ein Schmerz auftritt,
nach einer körperlichen Belastung,
nach einer ungewohnten Belastung,
mit einer starken Bauchpresse,
das ja beim Handeltraining passiert,
dann würde ich schon eher an einen leisten Herrn hier denken.
Und nicht unbedingt jetzt an ein Rezidiv von dem Morbus Hojkin.
Das finde ich eher weniger wahrscheinlich.
Wichtig ist aber jetzt,
dass erkannt wird, was führt zu diesem Ilius.
Es kann ja manchmal eine inkarzerierte Leistenherne sein.
Es kann aber auch eine Femoralherne sein.
Also eine Schenkelherne, die aber seltener ist.
Häufiger ist die Leistenherne.
Erst mal vielen Dank,
dass Sie sich jetzt noch mal auch bereit erklärt haben zu üben.
Das ist auch gut, das ist immer wichtig.
Es fallen Ihnen ja auch dann die Fachbegriffe ein.
Versuchen Sie in der Vorbereitungszeit,
die jetzt viel zu kurz war für Sie,
aber so etwas wie Vergrößerte Schilddrüße,
gleich übersetzen für Sie, was kann das heißen?
Stromer.
Ein Knoten, da können Sie ruhig sagen,
Stromer mit einem nodulus oder Knoten im rechten Lappen.
Stromernodosa wäre optimal.
Struppenflechte psoriasis.
Achten Sie bitte darauf, wenn Sie unter Stress kommen
und sich überlegen, dann haben Sie folgendes gemacht.
Dann haben Sie so gemacht.
Und ich habe Sie dann schlecht auf den Kopf.
Da versuchen Sie möglichst in der Prüfung nicht zu machen.
Ich weiß aber, dass das jeder Mensch hat,
wenn er unter Stress kommt, der eine platzt sich am Kopf
und der andere hält sich den Mund.
Versuchen Sie möglichst, Ihre Hände auf dem Tisch zu lassen.
Das ist besser.
Das lernen die Politiker heute in den Talkshows.
Die müssen lieber die Hände auf dem Tisch lassen.
Aber versuchen Sie das möglichst auch.
Ich wünsche Ihnen für Ihre Prüfung, ich bin da zuversichtlich,
dass Sie das in München schaffen.
Übermorgen, dass Sie eine gute Prüfung händen.
Dann würde ich sagen,
wir sehen uns dann wieder nächsten Donnerstag.
Dann sehen wir uns dann wieder.
Gut.
Nächsten Donnerstag um 6 Uhr.
Ja, 18 Uhr. Ich wünsche Ihnen allen einen schönen Abend.